[Music]
this video isn't for everybody let me
tell you who this video is for this
video is for the person that you may be
thinking about a Goliath in your life
Clyde doesn't necessarily mean the
biggest in your industry if you're
playing highschool ball the Goliath
maybe that kid that's 20 miles outside
of the school they're gonna be facing up
that everybody's calling this guy the
guide of your state California New York
Illinois and you're gonna face this guy
you know he's better than you're scared
of this guy right
that's your collide it may be in
business in a sales office there's a guy
that's killing everybody in sales and
you want to beat him but he's the best
in that office and he's much better than
you that could be your glide for
somebody else maybe in your state and
maybe in the industry and as you get
bigger
Goliath's get bigger and tougher to beat
and today I'm gonna share with you 14
things you need to know before facing
off a glide and before me telling you
the 14 points I'll tell you sir about
what happened to me in 2005 they may
give you some insight and clarity on
whether or not you want to face the
glide of your industry and again as I go
through this episode throughout the
entire time if you got any questions
thoughts comment comment below and if
you haven't yet subscribed to the
channel click on the subscribe button
right next to me right here to get
updates on future videos that come out
okay so let me get right into it first
of all in 2005 let me tell you where I
was at I was already making six figures
I didn't have a lot of money I just paid
off my 49 thousand dollars of debt and
I'm coming up and I get invited into
this meaning it's a hundred people in
this room okay
and all these hundred people that are in
the room 80% of them are ahead of me and
I'm trying to come out trying to come up
I'm really trying to compete with these
guys and I'm in the financial industry
at this point of my life I had already
made a decision I'm gonna be in the
sales business period and I'm gonna be
in the insurance and financial services
period which means I'm no longer looking
I'm not partying I'm done chasing
squirrels it doesn't excite me anymore
another new girl I don't get excited
about it I want to figure out a way to
get the best out of this guy and I would
stay up at night and I would be thinking
to myself I don't know why but I can't
go to sleep because I think I put on
this planet to do some very special in
my life there's no way in the world I
was just putting her to be an average
guy I was thinking those stars so if
you're that
that's also having those thoughts this
is gonna make a lot of sense to you know
it'll sense to you know give you some
clarity so I walk into this meeting and
speaker gets up and the speaker says
today I'm only speaking to one person
said okay see what he's gonna be saying
and he says today's message is not for
everybody today's message is for the
person that wants to be the best so I
like that opening line already then he
takes out this magazine okay and this
magazine is called Newsweek Tiger rules
five secrets of his dominance I'm
already excited because Tigers killing
it at that time and he says I'm by the
way I've never opened up this magazine
ever I've never opened up this magazine
it's crisp let me show you it is crisp
this has never been opened up okay and
you'll know why in a minute why it's
never been opened up and he tells the
stories about Tiger Woods he says listen
for the one person in this room that
wants to be the best that wants to be
the best here's what the best is
wire-like tiger point number one in a
magazine
it says genius is 99% perspiration this
was a message about hard work and he
goes off ten minutes timer if you don't
work hard if you don't do this if you
don't do that there's no way in the
world you stand a chance and he talks
about Tigers a work ethic then he says
point number two let the other guy get
nervous and I'm sitting there saying let
the other guy get nervous Tiger ways to
scare people used to intimidate people
by the way he looked at people by the
way he did this by the way he did that
and I'm a big guy when it comes down to
looking at eyes and studying eyes and
and I had a reputation a little bit of
going and telling a guy that was much
bigger than me at that time I was making
$20,000 a month this guy's making
$200,000 a month and we're in Phoenix
and I pulled him on someone he's done
giving his keynote and he knew who I was
I was coming up and I pulled him I said
let me let me say something to you I
have to say this for me more than I have
to say for you he says what's that I
said you won't even get close to the
size of a business I'm going to be
building and he says what did you said
there's no way in the world you will
even get close to the size of business
you I'm gonna be building now some may
call it cocky arrogant whatever you want
to call it that was more for me than it
was for him now he cursed me we went at
it it was in the
hotel lobby everybody's looking what is
going on with these guys we're both
about the same height but I had to say
that to him because I had to know that I
could go face somebody much bigger than
me and if I want to back down and get
scared or my spirits gonna get bigger
and Sam coming after you I have to
figure that part out about myself
maybe he says point number three don't
just dominate intimidate Tiger was
famous for intimidating his competition
I said okay that's that's exciting to me
right now
he says point number four have a sense
of the historic what I mean a sense of
the historic study history Tiger knows
his history Tiger does this Tiger knows
what it is to break the rectangular nose
Jack Nicklaus got the most you know
Tiger knows all and he's going on and
I'm like oh my gosh this is me because
all I do is I study history I love
studying history I love studying every
single thing about everybody in the
insurance space I want to know
everything I want to know the mistakes
who's done at best who's best at this
who's the greatest at this who made a
big fall base who did over here I wanted
to know every single thing so the books
I would read weren't just highlighted
they had things written in them they
were crumbled I had things typed out
pages and pages and pages of notes typed
up because I wanted to know history and
the last but not least never ever be
satisfied that's the thing about Tiger
Woods he says never ever be satisfied
you know what happened with number five
I was stuck you know why here's what I
was stuck it's very easy to say well you
know and understand how never be
satisfied I will never ever be satisfied
you have no clue if you're never never
ever be satisfied you know why here's
why what are you gonna do if somebody
puts a hundred million dollars in your
checking account right now wake up go
ahead and wake up in the morning so you
got a hundred million dollars in your
checking account week up in the morning
with the same fire in your belly so
that's the only thing that I said oh man
this one's gonna take me decades to
figure out whether I'm gonna get to the
point where I'm never gonna be satisfied
so he says this and I step out and I
said you know what I don't know what it
is I don't know what I'm feeling in my
stomach I can't even stop thinking about
this I went home I went on eBay I went
on every single magazine store I bought
every available copy of this magazine
every available copy of this magazine I
bought I kept the best quality one I
gave the rest away to the people that I
was mentoring out there
time but I kept the best copy and it's
the first one when I open up
I have tens and tens of these folders
here that I keep my notes and I type up
and then I came back and say hey Patrick
are you really that serious or just BS
in yourself that you want to go out and
go face off a Goliath
that's an are pretty serious path I made
a vision board and these are all the
quotes philosophies people that I admire
on things that they say their belief
system and I looked at at every single
day multiple times every day when I went
to work I created another one this other
one here has the greatest performance
obviously you see me in the middle there
with 14 years old 18 years old 19 years
old mean a military I'm big on I so
you'll see a lot of eyes on there and
then I made another one the future of
pbd why because I wanted to really test
this guy you know why this has nothing
to do with your Goliath this has to do
with you I'm talking to you this only
has to do with you and remember I told
you this message is not for everybody
some of you guys are watching and going
on news feed on your Facebook and you're
listening to this you're not the person
the person who wants to go off against
go I'll go face-off Goliath you can't
even move your head off the camera right
now your body's got the chills all over
your body because you thought about this
last thing you thought about it this
morning every movie you watch tears
comes down your eyes when you're
watching a warrior or you're watching a
you know glad your brave heart because
this stuff matters to you that's what
I'm speaking to in this video purely
okay so now here's a few things we need
to know before we face off a glide
number one it's not for everyone
very simple everybody claims they want
to do it but it's not for everyone
number two it is scary as hell it is so
scary it's not even funny because can
you imagine you going and telling the
guy way ahead of you I'm coming after
you you're putting yourself out there
LeBron says I'm chasing the ghost he
should never said it but he put himself
out there do you realize I've never been
a LeBron James fan until he said that
because I and I'm still not a fan but
when he said that I said you put
yourself out there now you got pressure
and he wants to show that this matters
to me
Kobe said my numbers not 23 I'm 24
because I'm one better than MJ even
though it never happened it's putting
yourself out there that's how you gain
to respect
from the people that are saying well
every time they ask Michael John who's a
person closest thing to you
he says Ben I've never seen nothing like
Kobe before you earn respect from
Goliath when you do that but it's scary
as hell let me tell you number three
you'll have anxiety attacks and panic
attacks I can't tell you how many
anxiety attacks and panic attacks I had
when I put myself out there I couldn't
sleep I was up I was Restless and we
waking up in the middle of night my
body's sweating my better sweat not
because I peed in my pants but because
I'm sweating all night long thinking
about this I would dream about it I
would have anxieties about it by the way
again someone's gonna say Pat this is
not healthy I understand if you say this
is not healthy because this video is not
directed to you the person who knows
exactly what I'm talking about you're
thinking about this stuff point number
four you'll be bullied and laughed at
for even thinking that it's possible for
you to face off the Gilad people gonna
say you're out of your mind you're gonna
be Joey you're never gonna be Joey
no one's meeting joy for 13 years no
one's beaten you know Jennifer for 28
years you think you're gonna break his
record you're crazy you are absolutely
crazy they'll make funny they'll create
rumors look at him he thinks he's this
he thinks he's gonna do this that
stuff's gonna happen number five you
have to be a bit off to even think this
is possible
you're not normal if you think this is
possible I want to I want tell you this
you have to be a little bit off you have
to be a little bit crazy you know some
people may even call you a psycho
there's no way in the world this guy
think this is possible
you have to be off you cannot be normal
to think you can face up a Goliath and
beat them next one as much hard work and
dedication as you think it takes it's
ten times more you think you're working
hard it's ten times more you think
you're really putting into the effort
it's ten times more again I'm reminding
you this is not for everybody point
number seven your family won't be too
happy because they won't see you too
much point number eight you will be
hospitalized for burnout or hard work
multiple times Mariano's is watching
this from you know behind the cameras
this has happened to me multiple times
one time we're in Jacksonville and I'm
giving this talk in Jacksonville and
while I'm speaking my legs are wobbly it
looks like I'm about to pass out the
room is full it is hot it's summertime
we finish I walk out I'm walking in the
parking lot with Paul all of a sudden I
collapse I tell Paul take me to the
emergency room we get in the RV I go to
the emergency room they set me up with
IVs I say doc what's going
with me since you're just exhausted they
gave me two IVs I was fired up we got in
to the RV drove down to Miami stayed up
two three four five o'clock in the
morning did it again the next day why
cuz that's the stuff you're gonna do a
few times when you push the envelope
it's just gonna be happening I by the
way some parents will watch this and say
I can't believe you my kids are watching
you telling my kid admires you how dare
you see this kind of stuff to my kids
ma'am
sir let me simplify something for you
the chances of your kid even doing this
is less than 1% because the person who's
going to do this is already thinking
about this stuff they just want some
direction I want to know when they face
off a god so don't worry about your kid
there's one percent chance that your
kids even gonna want to step up to
something like this having said that if
you think's you need to know about glide
here's a few thing number one glide is
much bigger than you number two
Goliath has more capital than you number
three
Goliath has a more experienced team than
you number four Goliath has a well-known
reputation number five delight has
better attorneys than you and number six
Goliath is more comfortable than you why
do I finish off with Goliath is more
comfortable than you there is nothing
like being number one because when you
become number one here's a few things
that happen everybody starts telling me
oh my gosh you're so amazing you're so
powerful I love you I've never met
anybody like you before you're so this I
feel like you're like better than
everybody else in a business and this
stuff is the worst thing you need to
hear because if you start hearing this
stuff and you believe it you are in deep
trouble you don't hear when you're
coming up because you want to hear it
once you hear it then your stomach's
whoa so how do you make sure your
stomach doesn't stay for very few
Goliath's stay hungry for a long time
bit you need to know that that is a
known very few some stay number one for
a few years some stay number one for
maybe a decade now a lot of people stay
number one for multiple decades it just
doesn't happen because eventually you
make some cool friends you hang out with
celebrities you have some celebrities on
speed dial with your phone they text you
back you show your friends look who just
texted me I'm so cool and people like oh
my god she's connected to the sky and
you know dude you see I was at this
party yesterday let me tell you I was
playing poker with that's just small
talk no one you know the guy that wants
to go and beat a real giant Goliath and
give a crap about celebrities and all
the sudden it's just
relationships I don't need to brag about
it to you I'm trying to do something big
with my life of course I'm gonna be
friends with these guys what do you
think they want to do you think they
want to be friends with Schmucks no they
want to be friends with people that also
perform him
yes that's inevitable that's a given
that's a different level of Goliath
right which leads me to you known these
things about collide the light has
everybody telling him he's amazing
the light hasn't worked as hard as he
once did delight isn't in touch with the
current market like he once was the
light doesn't speak to his customers
directly he's very difficult to get a
hold of they have so many different
assistants and people you got to go
through before you get to them they
don't respond to messages on social
media Goliath is collide I am the
greatest you are so lucky to be in
contact with me that's AG light that's
how they think that's why David beats
Goliath Goliath isn't as nimble as you
go I can't screw up let me explain what
happens when you're number one you know
what happens when you're number one all
the cameras on you every single one of
them everyone's watching you to make a
mistake so you know what happens to
glides when all the cameras on them they
they live in a bigger box now now they
really start living in a box because
whatever I say it's held against me I
can no longer be irresponsible I can no
longer be a little chippy if they're
gonna watch everything I say and people
write about me and they have to be so
proper and they forget that when they
were coming up yeah we're not proper
they were crazy they were weird
they were nimble they were off they were
a little bit irresponsible and people
said man this guy could go way off all
of a sudden if I say something wrong to
him but they lost that sizzle they lost
that sizzle by the way even the glides
watching right now they say that's right
I used to be like that and you know what
I want to get back to being like that
you can't you cannot you're afraid they
can't do it the lights cannot do it they
say they can do it they won't be able to
do it you'll know why they won't be able
to do it I want you deep into that topic
here
why they won't be able to do but they
got a lot to lose the lights can't
recruit the crazy ones
let me explain to why the lights can now
create a recruit the crazy ones slaton
recently signed with the LA Galaxy for
three million dollars you know what
China offered them the same time a
two-year contract four hundred million
dollars even 97 million dollars on the
table
you know why because salat means not
trying to go play for glide slot means
not just doing it for money Slaton wants
to do something that's never been done
before and that's bringing football to
America that calls that soccers Lawtons
on Jimmy Kimmel Jimmy Kimmel says it's
not and says you know when I play
football Jimmy Kimmel says we call it
soccer he says you can call it whatever
you want it's called football and it's
the most popular sport in the world
Jimmy says you're right
slop means bring in swagger to LA Slaton
wants people to yeah he's got bigger
plans on what he's doing the lights
can't recruit regular crazy ones you
can't recruit crazy ones because cedam
it's not just money
see glides try to recruit based on money
we'll give you this we'll give you that
well you know the guy that wants to face
off Goliath is like the what are you
talking about I don't care about that I
want to do something that's never been
done before I recruited many many
different people and when it comes down
to the conversation that it comes down
to them wanted to run with somebody like
us that we're coming up we're not the
biggest far from it there's a lot of
people bigger than us but we're the
fastest-growing one and when I sit down
and I tell them I say look for in order
for you to come with us you have to have
courage if you don't have courage and
you'd rather work with the biggest guys
in a marketplace we're not it but if
you're somebody that deep down inside
you want to work with the smaller guys
that's coming up faster than everybody
else I'm putting fear into everybody
else and you want to be a hero on that
kind of an organization worried who do
you want to be and you see them in front
of me they talk like yeah you know this
is behind me they're trembling so scared
because what if all of a sudden this
thing gets scary and they have to call
their mom you say mommy I'm scared it's
not for you that is not for you but the
ones that are crazies liked it that's
exactly what I want I want to run with
somebody like this it's a different
mindset I can't describe to you unless
if you've been in a position like that
there you know exactly what I'm talking
about now here's the thing last but not
least no matter how much smack we talk
about glides let me put something let me
simplify something here for you
he's still glide for a reason whoever
you're facing in your office that you
want to beat there's a reason why he's
the Goliath of the office there's a
reason why he's a glide to the industry
there's a reason why he's the biggest
the number one the best at whoever it is
whatever marketplace you want to compete
against he didn't get there by pure luck
he knows what he's doing so if you get a
little too comfortable thinking oh my
gosh I can beat this guy no problem
you're gonna lose in no time because
glides are very sharp still know you you
know what you have an edge over them but
you can't underestimate anyone of them
they still are there and have a lot of
experience over here so now having said
all this stuff here let me get into the
14 things you need to know if you want
to face off you've got number one you
need to know your weaknesses a lot of
times we know our strengths but you need
to know your weaknesses here's my
weakness here's my weakness here's my
weakness
here's your weaknesses here's your
strength you need to know your goliaths
weaknesses and strengths let me simplify
it for you so again number one your
weaknesses and strengths collides
weaknesses and strengths
you cannot face against his or her
strengths because you will lose let me
explain
if you and I gonna fight and I am known
for my kick is the best kick in MMA best
kick I crush people's ribs and I have
the best kick you cannot say I'm gonna
go get better than pattern kicks no you
got to get better in my you know maybe
on the ground game you got to get better
in the stand up game you got to get
better with your fight you got to get
better with your you gotta have
something that I'm weakened and you
become the best and then you face off in
that area so number three is take three
areas that you can master that's their
weaknesses your strengths and take it to
a whole different level where you're the
best in a marketplace in that okay again
your weaknesses strengths number one
your competitors weakness and strength
number to match your strengths and take
it to a whole different level against
their weakness you do that and then
battle in that area number four
don't try to beagle ID I see a lot of
people I was in a training one time
years ago and the speaker said model
everybody model everybody model
everybody and I'm like you know what I
don't want to model in everybody because
if I model somebody I can beat the model
what do you mean model everybody Cobie
model Jordan he's not gonna be Jordan
you model modern a there's a few moves
and stuff that I can learn from that
person but I want this however I can't
say I'm gonna walk like him I'm gonna
talk like him I'm gonna think I'm gonna
no you can't do that it's got to be
there you cannot be and look like the
light and faceoff glide number five
glides get bigger they tend to general
lies and they specialize less let me
explain when companies get bigger they
all of a sudden want to be everything to
everybody right what we're gonna sell
this and we're gonna sell this and we're
gonna sell this and we're gonna sell
this and we're gonna sell this no
problem let them do it that's when you
catch up because for you you let the
lights generalize you specialize you
specialize you specialize in one area
let them generalize and then when
they're generalizing they're grown like
this but you're growing like this and
then you catch up when you're
specializing then all of a sudden boom
you decide at that moment what things to
pivot but you got to catch up in order
to catch up to your guy or gal that
you're competing against you got to
specialize don't get caught up trying to
be everything to everybody and sell
every single product number six be a
niche player have a glide competed with
you in areas their weekend okay again I
talked about that briefly earlier be a
niche player number seven when you're
small appear bigger don't walk around
being afraid if you're afraid you know
they're gonna kind of see that you're
little you know these you're intimidated
by them when you're small walk tall you
know what I'm saying it's okay I know
they come who does he think it's just
walk tall you're okay have some
confidence you know I remember when we
first started a financial from PHP and
we didn't have a big headquarters we had
a small headquarters I got to make a
statement I went to got a massive office
space from a former billionaire in a
area that was the financial capital the
community I was in a target marketplace
that rubbed a lot of people the wrong
way and they said did you see the office
pad guy everybody talked about it when
you're small you got a pure big and by
the way we had nobody working in that
office if you were ever in the office it
was empty half the time it wasn't like a
smart financial decision it was a
statement by the way I could have been
wrong on that statement and people could
have said he never should have made that
decision that said I said oh I could
have been wrong in that statement but I
had to make that statement for people to
realize I'm trying to compete with
everybody next keep a low profile
initially this kind of contradicts what
I just said you still want to keep a low
profile meaning what
don't be too rowdy and don't rub too
many people the wrong way you just have
to get better
your goal at that time to get better
better better better better better
because you want a lot of people helping
you're gonna need a lot of help
you want to stay low don't be too loud
with calling everybody out just get
better better because you need some
alliances until you get bigger then
people can say who you are then and
you're gonna be pretty noisy because you
can't help it at that time your number
is gonna be noisy for your number 9 move
quickly move fast let me simplify some
for you if there is anything you need to
know about the guys that are getting
bigger they can't move as fast as you
you can move much faster if there's one
expectation a happy with the people I
work with is the following I will not
compromise speed I don't care how much
bigger we get I'll sit in our executive
meeting and I'll say listen
faster-faster-faster I don't want us to
be getting slower just because we're
getting bigger I want speed not want
execution I want efficiency but you
can't have all of it I want all of it I
am greedy in these three areas I want
speed I want execution I want efficiency
and I want it now you understand me I
want the best things now Pat it's too
hard you're putting pressure I don't
care you do whatever you want to do I
don't care what time you know I don't
care what things you do I don't
micromanage you but these three things
we're gonna be doing because those are
the things they're gonna have an edge
when you faceoff somebody much bigger
than you next if they come out with a
new product if good life comes out with
a new product you don't need to jump the
gun and mimic them with that same exact
product because then you become me too
me too me too me too me too me too me
too me too me too doesn't beat Goliath
okay you've got to be different to be
glide next point partner up with a
competitor who shares a common enemy as
you as glides become Goliath they create
a lot of enemies go befriend their
enemies it's very simple because they
also want to beat the same target here
right
go befriend their enemies next study
history similar to what Tiger was talked
about earlier have a sense of the
historic study history you got to study
history you can't just get cocky and
arrogant and think you're gonna beat
them no matter what you gotta study a
lot of history because this stuff is not
easy this is a lot of work and there's a
lot of people I want to put you out
number 13 let other competitors wear
them down let me explain to what this
means let other competitors wear them
down so LeBron James everybody wants
them to come to LA and play for the
Lakers including myself I'm a die-hard
Laker fans Laker fan and I know I want
LeBron to come to the Lakers it'd be
great if we have him and quiet Leonard
now if LeBron James stick
- his narrative and sticks to his
philosophy which is worth forming up
he's been to seven eight nine straight
finals he's the greatest is this
distance no LeBron is very strategic
LeBron doesn't need to go to the West
you know why because LeBron says oh my
gosh there's four teams in the West that
could potentially beat me so guess what
I don't need to worry about ever going
into the West why would I put myself
through that misery where I'm tired by
the time I get to the finals I'm gonna
stay in the East first rounds gonna be
easy because the Eastern Conference
hasn't had real competitors since the
80s when it was the Knicks you know the
the bulls and and and then you know the
Pistons they haven't had it for a while
I'm just gonna stay here let them kill
off each other and then I'll just have
to face one of the best teams in the
West that's LeBron so as much as
everybody would like for a LeBron go to
the west you really think it's gonna do
that if he does it respect from me to
you I think he's gonna stay somewhere in
the East maybe even go to the 76ers if
he sticks to the same narrative of
staying in the East so let let your
competitors let other competitors fight
them off
you just keep focused on improving
yourself and last but not least point
number 14 it's probably more important
than all the other 13 points combined
and by the way when I tell you what
number 14 is you will say my gosh I
cannot believe how much this makes sense
you'll see why Barack Obama a one-term
senator be John McCain with a resume the
size of a Bible why he'd be Mitt Romney
a quarter billion dollar Network why
Trump never been in politics ever before
beat out Hillary Clinton Jeb Bush and
all these other candidates on how's that
even possible you will find out why a
small player like Apple came out going
up against a giant IBM you will find out
why some of these guys are coming up and
they beat the bigger guys because number
14 is that powerful it is more important
than the other thirteen combined and
number fourteen is a point I will not be
sharing in this video for obvious
reasons because every single one of my
competitors watches this video and they
want to know exactly everything that
we're doing at number fourteen I will
not give up however maybe at our first
value team a live conference that we
have when we cross a million subs I may
share it with you in a very smaller
group setting the point is this year if
you are somebody that is listening to
this and you're still here with us at
the end and you're similar said oh my
gosh
got the chills all over my body this
message was directed to me I actually
wonder what you think number 14 is so I
want you to send me a tweet at Patrick
made David and tell me Pat I think
number 14 is this I'm curious to know
exactly what you think number 14 is for
some of you that watches and said Pat I
also want to go by that Tiger Woods
magazine well let me tell you what
issued is it's June 18 2001 Newsweek
magazine let me validate that yep June
18 2001 Newsweek magazine and I'm
curious to know who's gonna buy him and
when you do buy them I don't own this
stuff on eBay or different places you
buy it from when you do buy it sem you
tweet and say Pat I buy it on or on
Instagram but for some of you that don't
want to wait til you get the magazine
you want to read the article Tiger rules
click on a link below and think Mario
he's gonna leave the link below for you
to read that entire article and last but
not least if you want everything I cover
today in this video if you seen Pat I
need every one of these things type that
on a PDF for me to look at no problem we
got that PDF as well click on the link
below to go on Patrick midday be calm
and you'll get the details of everything
I covered today on a PDF free to you
where you can sit there and strategize
on who your Goliath is and how you gonna
take at the glide you're going up
against whatever that Goliath is to you
with that being said questions thoughts
comments comment below you haven't
subscribed to the number one channel on
YouTube for entrepreneurs click on a
link below and that little alert button
you see click on that as well because
you'll be part of notification squad
every time a video comes out they'll get
texted out to you take everybody bye-bye